what I want to do in this video is
explore how trade imbalances in theory
should be resolved by freely floating
currencies so let's just say at the
beginning of our time period like we did
in the last video that the exchange rate
between the Chinese won and the US
dollar is 10 to 1 so we have 10 won so
the last time people traded these
currencies they exchanged 10 won for one
US dollar so one one and when I say
dollar I'm going to implicitly mean the
US dollar now let's think about 2
entrepreneurs in each of the countries
or one in each of the country so let's
talk about a Chinese entrepreneur so we
are in China here and he makes dolls
he makes dolls let me draw one of the
dolls and in order to profitably sell a
doll he needs to sell them for 10 won so
sell so needs needs to sell for 10 won
if he's able to sell for the equivalent
of 10 won in the United States and we
won't talk a lot about shipping and what
currency you would have to paint in all
of that then he can pay all of his needs
maybe even the the shippers across the
Pacific maybe their employees are also
Chinese so they want their money in wan
and obviously most of the cost would be
for manufacturing this doll and all of
his employees want to be paid in wan his
own rent for the factory or even his own
rent for his own house it all has to be
paid in one so this is what he needs to
sell his doll for 10:1 and at the
current exchange rate that would be one
u.s. dollar now let's go across the
Pacific let's go across the Pacific
let's go to the United States and let's
say that we have another entrepreneur
who's making soda are making Cola for
export so let me draw a can of cola cola
and similar to this guy in China he
needs to sell his product abroad for the
equivalent of a dollar so that it can
cover shipping costs and manufacturing
costs and the high fructose corn syrup
and all of that so needs needs to sell
for for one US dollar and once again he
cares about
dollars because he has to pay his own
mortgage in dollars his employees need
to be paid in dollars maybe the shippers
he used they only accept dollars so this
is how both of these characters think
about it
now at the current exchange rate so at
this current exchange rate let's say
that the demand for these dolls that
there is demand for $100 in China or
sorry at the current exchange rate there
is demand for $100 in the United States
this guy is exporting and so is this guy
well make it a very simple they're only
focused on export so at at current
exchange at current current exchange
I'll do it for both there is for the
doll guy there is demand there's demand
for demand for 100 100 100 dolls in the
United States so what does that mean
that means that if you if he can sell
these dolls for $1 which is equivalent
to 10:1 then there's going to be a
hundred people in some time period let's
say it's a year or a month who are going
to be willing to buy the dolls at that
price and let's say also at this current
exchange rate in China in China 50
people are willing to buy this Cola so
the current exchange rate demand demand
for 50 50 cans demand for 50 cans in
China obviously these are ridiculously
no numbers but we're just dealing with
simple numbers to help our thinking and
let me write the add current exchange
rate as well at current exchange rate
current exchange rate so what we're
saying is that in China he needs to get
a dollar at the exchange rate that's
10:1 so if he were to in a store in
China or to a distributor in China maybe
sell each of these cans for 10:1 there's
demand for 50 cans in China now what's
going to happen here I think some of
y'all might already see that a trade
imbalance is developing so what's going
to happen here so this guy he likes
doing this and this guy likes doing it
so what's going to happen in this time
period this Chinese guy is going to ship
over he is going to ship over 100
dollars
so he's going to ship over 100 dolls to
the United States so let me write this
down this is China
this is the US over here and what's the
u.s. going to do well the u.s. is going
to ship over the u.s. is going to ship
over essentially he remember he's
selling this in the United States
so each 10-1 is $1 so for each doll he's
going to get $1 so he's going to get
back $100 he is going to get back 100 US
dollars for his dolls and then and then
once he gets back 100 US dollars for his
dolls he's going to want to convert them
into one so then he will try try to
convert the 100 100 dollars into into
one so this is what will end up
happening for this guy let's say these
are the only two people trading between
China and the United States just to
really simplify things now let's think
about what happens on the right side
over here this guy is going to ship 50
Cola cans to China so we have cola can
right over there Cola he is going to
ship 50 of them to China from the United
States and what is he going to get back
in return well they're going to it's
being sold to Chinese distributors so
they're going to pay him in one so for
each can at the current exchange rate or
the at the cat in the cart price he's
going to get 10:1 so when you when you
convert it back when you convert it or
he's going to get 10:1 per can so 10:1
times 50 is 501 500 501 is what he's
going to get and then he's going to try
to convert try to convert let me write
that in a different color just to just
really for the sake of it so he's going
to try to try to convert because he has
to pay his expenses in dollars he is his
501
into into now what's the exchange rate
that he wants to his goal is in to to
cover his cost he has to get 10 to 1 so
500 1 into $50 into 50 into $50 let me
make it clear this guy thinks he's going
to get 10 1 for every dollar so he wants
to convert his hundred dollars into
1,000 won so let me write it here 1,000
I should have written it over here but
let me write 1,000 1 over here so what
just set up if these are the only people
trading goods and currency in this time
period when we just set up well clearly
this guy is shipping more value to the
US then this guy is shipping to China
there is a trade imbalance if you think
of it in terms of dollars this guy is
shipping $100 worth of goods to the US
this guy is only shipping $50 worth of
goods to China so there's a net trade
imbalance of $50 China's shipping $50
more the US and the other way around if
you think about it in 1 it would be a
trade imbalance of 500 won and because
of that because of that this guy is
trying to convert many more dollars into
one then this guy is trying to convert
the other way around notice there is
more demand more demand more demand for
1 then dollars what's going to happen
especially if these are the only two
people trading if these are the only two
people trading this guy is going to say
hey you know I've got I've got 10:1 let
me convert it in two dollars it'll be
just like what we saw in the last video
and obviously there will be more actors
here but whenever you this guy is more
this guy has more stuff to convert than
this guy in fact if these were the only
two people trading he wouldn't even be
able to convert all of his currency into
into one because there's only 501
available on the market this guy thinks
he should get a thousand won and
obviously if the price of the wand goes
up like we see in the previous video
maybe there'll be more people who want
to convert one or maybe fewer people
who'd want to convert dollars so we can
you can think about all of those but I
really want to think about how this will
this will potentially resolve the trade
imbalance so we see we have a situation
more demand
on more demand for Wanda dollars there's
a demand for thousand won here
there's only 501 being sold or you could
view it the other way there's only
demand for $50.00
there's only demand for $50.00 and
there's $100 being sold either way
there's an imbalance so what's going to
happen well you're going to have you're
going to have either depending on how
you want to view it you could have you
could say that the price of the dollar
of the dollar will go down or you could
say that the price of the one will go up
and the dynamics would be like we saw in
the last video this guy over here would
sell a couple of his wan and they say
wow there's really there's this guy over
there who really wants to buy it and
then maybe he'll keep saying well you
know what instead of instead of instead
of giving me instead of giving me a
dollar for every ten of Maiwand why
don't you give me a dollar for every
nine of Maiwand or eventually why don't
you give me a dollar for every eight of
Maiwand and so he'll keep raising the
price of the one he'll he'll keep he'll
keep giving fewer and fewer wands for
each of the dollar and let's say this
goes on for a little bit and I really
want to explore the trade amounts let's
say at some point and obviously maybe
more and more people come into the
market so eventually it clears because
right now there isn't enough wand for
this guy but as you can see the price of
the wand goes up so after all of this
because of this trade imbalance because
more people want to convert dollars into
one than one into dollars the currency
changes so you could imagine and I'm
just going to make up some numbers here
that the one becomes more expensive it
was 10:1 to the dollar now maybe it is
eight eight one eight one two dollar
eight one $2.00 so this is where we get
to eventually get to eventually because
of this supply-demand imbalance right
over eight one $2.00 now what's the
reality over here this guy over here
this guy over here he needs to sell his
dolls for 10:1 which before was the
equivalent of one dollar but now how
much is he going to sell his wand for
how he needs to sell for 10:1 that's
eight one per
dollar right so let's let's think about
how much his dolls cost so his dolls in
the US now that the wand has appreciated
they were ten one ten one and then times
we have one dollar one dollar for every
eight for every eight one so this is
going to be equal to the wands cancel
out this is really just dimensional
analysis you might have learned in
chemistry so 10 over eight is what
that's one and one-fourth this is a
dollar twenty-five so this is one point
two five dollars notice the price of his
dolls went up in the United States in
terms of dollars and let's think about
what happened to the cola manufacturer
the cola manufacturer right over here
cola so his cost or hit the pricing
needs to sell them for our one dollar
one dollar and now what's the exchange
rate one dollar let me write it the
other way because I need to cancel out
the dollars we have eight one eight one
for every one dollar for every one
dollar dollars cancel out eight times
one he'll now his selling price and the
unita
will now be eight one will now be eight
one so notice neither of these people
changed their prices in terms of their
home currency no change in price at all
but because of the currency movements
because the wand became more expensive
this guy's goods the Chinese
manufacturers goods are now more
expensive in dollars and the American
manufacturers goods are now less
expensive in one so what's going to
happen what's going to happen here at a
dollar there was a demand for a hundred
dollars in the United States but now
that the price has gone up now that the
price has gone up to a dollar
twenty-five now there will only be
demand demand now there will only be
demand let's say they're now at this
higher price now there's only demand for
$50 $50 in the United States and let's
say this guy over here before there was
demand for 50 cans of his Cola in China
because it was ten ones but now the
price has gone down so let now you can
imagine that there is demand or actually
I should say there's demand for
50 dolls not 50 there's demand for $50
and now because this guy's price has
gone down
now instead of demand for 50 cans maybe
there's demand for and I'll just make up
a number 80 cans maybe there is now
demand for 80 cans so what just happened
to the trade imbalance before in terms
of either currency we were buying more
dolls and if you think about it from the
US perspective and shipping fewer Cola
but now that has note that that we're
buying fewer dolls because it's now more
expensive the United States and we're
shipping more Cola so I don't even know
how this math works I don't know let you
figure that out but as one currency gets
more and more expensive those exports
the demand for those exports from those
countries are going to go down like we
saw with these dolls and on the other
side as the other currency gets cheaper
and cheaper and cheaper the demand for
those exports will go up because in
other currencies it will look cheaper
and eventually you should have some type
of trade balance